good afternoon everyone
a very warm welcome to this online
dialogue titled
what are you hungry for this is part of
the ongoing exhibition
hungry design at the national design
center
which is curated and presented by top
awards asia
supported by the design singapore
council and the national design center
exhibition is designed by farm and
branding done by roots
today's dialogue consists of mainly
three portions
we will be starting off with a short
sharing by each of our panelists
where they will be talking about the
exhibited works
following that we will proceed with a
panel discussion
before ending off with a q a segment
where the panel will be taking questions
from you the audience
moderating today's session is mr henry
ho
president and creative director at gtdi
a multinational design firm based in
tokyo
with us today on the panel we have isuke
tachikawa
design strategist and ceo of no signer
erico kawakami art director and graphic
designer
shun kawakami branding and art director
at atlas inc joshua brydenbach
founding partner and executive creative
director
at rice a vietnam-based brand
consultancy
jonathan yuen founder and creative
director of
roots an independent interdisciplinary
design studio based in singapore
last but not least director and
co-founder of cross-disciplinary
design practice from selwyn low
you can find out more about our panel
members later
on during their sharing as well as on
the design singapore council website
under the events tab let us now welcome
our panel members for today's dialogue
session
hello everybody can you hear me
hello henry hi everybody
hi hi hello hi thanks for joining
great first up
we have isuke tachikawa design
strategist
and ceo of no signer tachikawasan please
uh hello brady uh
please uh please excuse me for
proceeding in japanese
foreign
[Music]
next up we have erico kawakami
art director and graphic designer
kawakami-san please
[Music]
is
foreign
you
know
[Music]
foreign
m
[Music]
this
foreign
each of this
thank you kawakami-san next up we have
sun kawakami branding and art director
at atlas inc kawakami-san please
um hi uh this is shinkalgami i'm founder
of addressing uh web director and
blogging data
also my assistant designer thomas
he joined this webinar for helping
language
you know my english term also thomas can
you hear me
yeah i can hear you okay good
so my company name is outrageous
independently global branding
consultancy
and design we conduct all creativity
and design as in tokyo branching
osaka kyoto and charizard
so we design almost everything uh
include bubba
and it vision philosophy strategy
and brand identity logo graphics and web
natural art and technology and also
consulting for the service and
hospitality fashion
music that's kind of abandoned
atmosphere
and also design direction for
architecture interior landscape design
so
you know we conduct all greatly and fine
so um first this design
our product displayed in this exhibition
this pack is designed for hotel hotel
satyayam
it's in india
this is uh japan honey
a little bit very organic and natural
and so
this design concept and purpose is
bilingual communication for global
market
because this hotel uh so many
largest so many global people
and watches so we try to
make creating japan
atmosphere and also global atmosphere
and
providing our communication so um
you know i'm i'm always thinking about
bordering uh possibilities for plants
so this hotel now now this whole thing
at least on
michigan staff hotel and singapore good
design roads
and a group of design hotels
and next um next hotel project is in
china this is very
uh leia place
in china because this place
can get onsen what should you say also
in english
also in the hot spring thomas yeah like
a hot spring
hot spring okay so this place is a hot
spring place but you know chinese people
is not popular uh on same desert and hot
spring measles
but this owner loves onsen in japan they
coming
to japan so many times in for
onsen retreat so they want to make
hot spring results in china it's a kind
of
maybe only one uh only one hospital
visiting china so
this product's owner is chinese and
architecture and landscape by bangkok
designer team
development architecture and also also
branding by my company so my
company is based in japan but
i'm trying to get global project
so this project our work scope is
logo graphics and signage and packaging
almost everything without
designing the interior and
try to we could try to use trading
language japanese this time it's
been japanese english and chinese
and this project in shibuya this is
a hotel called tokyo this
their project concept is in uh to bring
back
music culture in shibuya so shibuya is a
very
young city a foreign city
but from now a little bit
born in the city so we try to bring back
high quality fashion and music culture
and
design to new experience in culture
so we also designed signage
[Music]
someplace and also i mean key design
and next is my cafe
this is my cafe inaugural
[Music]
yeah yeah this this cafe is uh located
next to our office it's in the same
building
connected to it yeah
so this project i was trying to combine
japanese professional
and also new coffee
trend sideways coffee culture
design so design looks like
international but you know
items is very traditional japanese items
we are using
so nx is a koi pizza this is a pizza
dining out in the park
in oklahoma prefecture
so this is this plant
to make new culture and rice
and for new generation of family
in oklahoma city
oklahoma council
outside so summer is
very good but winter it's so cold really
difficult to interfere but
we are trying to new experience
outside of restaurants
this is small kind of kitchen
and signage and graphics and this is a
drinking car
sometimes move to the other part
for the events
and packages almost everything and also
collaborating with
uh yuna gaba
he's very popular now um one of the most
famous illustrator in japan now
so try to
get young custom
family indicates
so next one this is dollars
store and plant uh interior designed by
kendall kumar he's one of the master
japanese artists so we collaborate
um umass tradition japan
um japan interdesign
try to combine a little bit fitting
american diner
and donuts like this and packaging
so uh my company this is my company for
page
uh you can see our statement um
we design create sustainable business
and culture through societal branding
and design
so such a blending means almost say
meaning
of sakura economy it's important thing
this is saturating it's
my image so combined to
uh vision accessibility and business
to make new business and culture
so my design rooting the japanese
aesthetics
with a global pathway to create new body
and innovation to for
a new era okay almost for me thank you
thank you kawakami-san next up we have
joshua brydenbach founding partner
executive creative director at rice
joshua please
thank you very much it's a real honor to
be here
thank you to all the organizers and the
other speakers
so my company creates
a brand strategy and visual identity
primarily
and often we get the opportunity to work
on packaging
the packaging is an incredibly exciting
area to be working in and
i'm very happy to discuss a few of our
packaging solutions today um
we look at packaging as sculpture
something that we can immediately give
to
our clients audiences that they can
touch
and feel and that makes it an incredible
communicator uh we're very lucky to um
get to work on packaging for our clients
because sometimes
um clients may not have something as
tangible
as that huge opportunity
you can go to the next page
and we believe that things that are made
and traded
next page these are kind of in sequence
are
windows into cultures
they can amplify voices
and broadcast extraordinary stories
and on the next page our studio can not
talk about
packaging without talking about this
project of ours
uh it's for a company called marut
chocolate we did this
nearly 10 years ago and it was our
studio's first
opportunity to create something like
this
in vietnam as we were based in vietnam
this company
is today still crafting
vietnamese cacao into a really
exceptional
world-class product and this package has
been
kind of a little delivery device sent
out all over the world
to tell people something about about
vietnam
and of course about chocolate on the
next page uh
when we met then we were introduced to
this story this
and we were immediately aware
of the opportunity we had to to tell
this extraordinary story
through design of um with a rare
and exquisite raw material which was
being crafted hunted down and crafted by
craftsmen into
something really special
next stage please um
through the history of this company
we've been able to work on
um many products for them
and i wanted to talk about one specific
one because i i think it's been
um of interest to the organizers
and this was a newer product
coming out of meru chocolate which was
called provisions maroon
and on the next page we can see that
it's really uh focused in on
just the basic raw materials so
uh two of these products actually come
from the process of making
chocolate one is just the cracked uh
cacao bean and one is um
cacao powder which someone might use to
make hot chocolate or something but
that's
a byproduct of making cocoa butter and
the other product is a is a chocolate
spread and what's
really exceptional about the product is
it carries all these flavors that are
quite unique to vietnamese chocolate
next page please um
this was kind of maybe the first
opportunity to
focus in and portray something that's
really true to the brand which is
going out into the field and doing
something very simple
from the earth and that brought us to a
design solution
which was not only um quite sustainable
on the next page
but also talks about just simplicity
and actually being out in nature we
wanted to evoke
ideas of sort of camping and something
that's
um a very um
almost nostalgic sort of provision that
would be
shelved in somebody's cupboard
but this kind of rough and tumble
can was something that um we uh
we worked very closely with the client
to produce uh which
would be hopefully something that
somebody would hang on to
and therefore be a little bit more
sustainable
the next page
uh this is a completely different
project now this is a product coming out
of japan
this is um a
team of young people who were
creating um a new matcha brand
and they wanted to portray matcha not in
a really traditional sense but
in a very contemporary sense and
uh what we were inspired by here the
story that we found so inspiring
was the the material itself matcha which
is
very very very pure uh and
sort of un unadulterated like
just pure leaf and uh we helped them
name this company
um we all agreed that this idea of just
pure material
was kind of the uh the inspiration
behind everything
and on the next page
um this is actually the final solution
of the packaging
you can see how we're kind of trying to
tell the story of material by just
punctuating the material itself
and the the outer package the outer box
we're using
different types of material paper to say
different things about the
matcha material inside which is three
different
roasts and blends and just using um
embossing and on the next page
uh we're taking that a bit further uh
the product
came with a recycled ceramic
vessel which also has this the logo
coming out of the material
and the matcha itself is housed in mylar
which we wanted to bring in as a
contrasting material
something very rough something very raw
a bit traditional
and something very futuristic like mylar
talking about material in a different
way and on the next page
we also included a little instruction
zine which was
uh produced uh with
um vintage uh
photocopy machines so you have raw kind
of
black toner as another material
so we want to sort of introduce
many different kinds of materials to
the user as they get closer and closer
to
the actual material we're talking about
which is pure matcha
so the whole thing is an experience and
material
next page please
that's uh just a page of the interior so
we simply used green paper to talk about
the matcha
and printed black thermal toner
with the xerox on top the nice effect
another project which uh wanted to tell
a story of work of simplicity
of pride and this is a vietnamese beer
this is a vietnamese craft beer which
wanted to
not present itself like um
like a very high-end craft beer but
rather a craft beer for everyone
kind of craft beer for for every day
and on the next page we see
our inspiration here we um helped rename
this company
as rooster beers and the rooster um
has a quite strong meaning in vietnam a
simple
creature companion simple hard-working
everyday and we also combined that with
this sort of
typographic vernacular of of work
of of um these are
um coming from
uh work shirts uh work trucks and uh
simple
sort of typographic forms that have
happened around this idea of work
on the next page is the
the beer um series of cans
which hopefully everyone's enjoying
after work
and not daring work but um it's really
all about just
emphasizing that that simplicity and
straightforwardness of um of a really
well made
very well crafted but simple and
accessible beer
and on the next couple pages are just a
few
more images
and on the next page i think the cans
look really nice
crushed something completely different
uh this was also in collaboration with
maroon chocolate we were asked to
collaborate with with them and
a vietnam based um
fashion brand called karen and karen
is becoming renowned for this specific
silhouette this really
beautifully crafted dress
and it's made by hand using
techniques that are traditional in the
making of traditional vietnamese aoya
which is the traditional
vietnamese dress and
this company is very much about craft
and things being handmade
and on the next page it's a little bit
of our research
coming together photographically
covering
both things that are coming from this
uh handcrafted
clothing company and also ingredients
of meru chocolate and karem's initiative
was to bring more flavors in
they're very inspired by nature and they
wanted to bring
new flavors from vietnam into this
vietnamese chocolate
one being tamarind and the other name
coconut
our solution was quite simply on the
next page
um to work directly with the creative
director
of karen he's the designer of all
the clothing that this company puts out
and he
essentially collaborated with us to
create a pattern
for a dress that we then um
envisioned in paper and we brought that
together to sort of
capture the spirit of the clothing
the next page you can see a little bit
more how that came together
um to create a really unique unwrapping
situation and to tease that
very alluring gold wrapper
underneath next page is
just another detail of that
okay next page please
um this is a different project this is
uh
it's a company in vietnam called four
piece um and it started with a pizza
pizza restaurant called pizza for peace
and
the founders uh masako and sane
hired us to
help them with their brand architecture
and their brand strategy
and their overall visual identity and
that's a very very big project that i
will not show today but i want to talk
about something that we
created together to get to know each
other we simply created
a wine label for them which we
envisioned as a sort of
store a pictorial story of their origin
story
this couple began making uh pizza
parties in their backyard in tokyo
they moved to ho chi minh city for
another type of work but ended up
opening this pizza restaurant which was
all about
happiness and making uh pizza
sharing that with people we depicted
that story on this wine label for them
and it was essentially our part of our
research phase of getting to know them
well
the next page you can see the bottles
when they rotate around you sort of get
this
never ending and beautiful story which
would send the message
to the customer about
sort of the background of the
brand and the background of the
restaurant they would be sitting in
next page please so
uh i wanted to keep that as brief as
possible but
when asked what am i hungry for i think
uh you know design is an opportunity to
make change
to make something better to make
something more meaningful and uh
as designers we're all really lucky to
partake
in that situation of making change
and ultimately on my final slide
i think what we can always remember is
that
design whether it's something small
like a package uh is actually a vehicle
to
to envision uh a better future it can
make an impact in someone's life
it can tell a wonderful story and can
broadcast something from
a misunderstood place
okay thank you for now
thank you joshua next up we have a pair
from right here in singapore
jonathan van creative director at roots
as well as shelvin low
director at farm over to you
carol thanks charlotte hi everyone
we are live in the national design
center
we have love to have everybody here
today but uh
uh we'll show you the exhibition i think
jonathan will start this session yes
hi um my name is jonathan so um i'm
really
uh it's a pleasure to share these
sessions with
everyone
and everyone is attending this session
so um just a quick start uh my name is
jonathan so i run the studio called
roots
based in singapore we do branding
graphic designs packaging designs prints
to exhibition designs and you know and
book designs and all sorts so um
just kind of coincide with these teams
you know as a studio what i'll be hungry
for
um i just kind of have a long thought
and to keep
to put it simple is that we know we
always try to tell stories
through design with timeless ideas in a
contemporary visual sensibility
that just kind of run through with all
the works that we have done so far
um for the purpose of these sessions
which is regarding emotive designs and
packaging so i just kind of
picked three projects to share with you
uh
on our creative process how we came to
think uh in terms of how we solved the
the design brief uh with the aspect of
automotive designs
and and also how do we tell the stories
of our clients
is a local uh pure producer of a pure
organic raw coconut water
so previously they have their product
logos
with the packaging and everything but um
they actually came to us to
kind of like engage us to take a fresh
look and
how can we help them to rebrand and
better communicate their story
so basically they are one of the fews uh
i would say probably the only one in
singapore they do high pressure
processing of coconut water
so in the sense that yeah what the
coconut water that they kind of like
produce is
untreated is really pure and organic
so the one of the reasons one of the
aspects of
pure untreated coconut water is that it
eventually will turn pink
in the packaging as time goes by when
they are exposed to sunlight
so it actually becomes a kind of an uh
like a like a point where it creates
like a lot of
enquiries from consumers like why is my
why is focused i bought tempe is it
still okay
you know so we actually trying to solve
the problem by
kind of like um take the whole packaging
but
we kind of completely take away all the
designs and everything colors and
everything and
we branded the whole thing of course and
then keep it as naked as possible
we wanted to show that the coconut water
the process of it turning pink and in in
in the process of that we're trying to
educate consumers that
by looking at your coconut water
tempering is a marker of that this is a
pure
organic coconut water that is untreated
so
the whole packaging is we only use white
color in
including the nutritional informations
and all the necessary uh
product information so that the consumer
can see
through the bottle as much as possible
and there's only one
black labels that organic coconut water
that kind of make it stands out
so we actually engaged photographer
jovian lim to help us
craft a series of photography images to
kind of communicate this aspect
and we also
kind of design a range of packaging as
well so this is a cotton box that using
the
type of logo type and the typography
styles
of coco loco that we developed for it
and then you know we just keep it simple
and then we also develop a special uh
structures to hold six bottles together
so these are for like you know online
order step six pack
then uh you know the delivery people can
easily kind of pick and
you know they give a six bottle at the
time
yeah so you can see that you know the
coco loco sometimes
it can be usually when it's fresh from
the factory
it will it's a clear bottle for about a
week
so once uh once they're exposed to light
and so eventually it will turn pink but
it doesn't diminish the quality the
focal of the coconut water
so um the next project uh which is also
very interesting in the sense is that
it's something that
i'm sure is quite uh familiar with
all the singaporeans and malaysians so
what we have here is a delicacy called
ota so ota is basically a fish paste
uh maybe fish fresh rice like macaroons
and you know
and the most recent one there's some
salmon
uh can taste as well so all these are
wrapped inside banana leaves and then
grill
over a chapel of fires and it just kind
of like a
package with the toothpick at two ends
so it's a very traditional
uh favorite local delicacies and if
either you can eat by itself or even if
you're
so our client is actually uh libby and
brothers
they are one of the uh local uh company
they're famous for nasi lemak and ota
and they came to us to kind of like
conceptualize
a new brand for our new stores in
chinese airport
so we kind of like you know engaged
uh like and uh how to say english's
project with the thought like
you know we wanted to kind of preserve
the traditional spirits of it
i also want to kind of elevate it for a
newer generations uh younger generations
in the sense and especially in the uh in
airports so where you have a lot of
foreigners traveling across
so we wanted to kind of like introduce
this uh
this uh brand for for for this delicacy
as a local
kind of you know it's a local food that
is uh
this that is famous for so you can see
that this is the the
the look of author that most people
recognize and remember for so basically
we just abstract and
you know just we just call auta and then
we just abstract it in the very simple
graphic and they just called water
and then we created a series of motifs
actually this also kind of reminds
people how ortega is made usually
it's like there's a lot of kind of a
towel together over a open fire and
grilling
so this kind of also give us the idea
like how we created a simple motif that
true to the spirit of it so from there
we created
the whole series of packaging for for
the for the offerings so um for ota
they not just doing traditional order
but they kind of push it forward as well
and they use ota as an ingredient to
kind of like uh
use it in a new way so they have otta
burger which is
hota as a patty then they have ota rolls
and you can see here altar fries so we
also kind of help
help them to uh uh create a new
technique called fresh steak on the
classics so all type in the classics
so these are the packagings that we have
like
the burger box so we keep it simple
we use the color palettes of the brands
and then
we use a motif and then this is the nasi
lemak
um packaging box and you might wondering
what is all the circle is about so it's
actually uh
the the the the composition of the
ingredients so when you open the box
like the necessary mud rice the it can
be these anchovies
the sambals and everything is actually
placed in that grid form
so it's kind of gives you a prelude to
the content
and this is the paperback
and this is also a series of
uh packagings for the author so ota
when they uh when they kind of like
start serving
and and as a takeaway so we actually
need to have all these cut holes at the
top
to kind of let the steam to go off
because they are freshly uh grilled from
from the fire so um like so we also have
like
packaging for the it can be switched
anchovies and anchovies with peanuts
which is a very famous and you know
much love delicacies here so this is uh
some quick look in
the packaging for the ota and then this
is the anchovies and the anchovies
peanut
so um you can see we use the color
um to kind of like uh kind of like
highlights the
almost the taste of it as well so
apparently it's
so successful with our consumers that uh
libya and brothers actually take this
and
start selling in you know libya and
brothers main store as well you can kind
of find it in
all the libra brothers so and the
last project that we're gonna share with
you um this one is not so much about
packaging
but more on the emotive designs that
um it's also remain remain uh one of my
favorite projects that
um that i have the privilege to
kind of work on so it's actually this is
an exhibition designs that is uh
conceived originally uh working with rj
paper so algae paper is a paper merchant
locally
so they came to us like to collaborate
for
uh exhibition a small exhibition in
singapore
so um our task is like what can we do
with paper to kind of like um
tell the story about papers in the sand
in the in the simplest sense
so for us we start to ask ourselves you
know paper you know people use in
design packaging you know books and
everything
so it's something that we can see you
can smell i like to smell books
it's something we can touch but what
about the senses of sound
is something that people don't talk
about like you know you hear
papers you know paper sounds so it's
kind of
because interest you kind of raise the
interesting questions like can we
you know have do something about papers
and sound
so we started this idea like how about
we let the paper sinks
so we actually start to kind of tie with
the idea like maybe we can let people
kind of feel the touch and play with the
paper people textures and everything
but at the same time as if the paper is
alive and start making sounds
or sing to you so we work with musicians
we kind of select the papers and stuff
like that
and then we started to create a series
of sound very specific
to different types of paper stock and
then
this is a very quick like our exhibition
setup space
in uh singapore and this is the setup so
it's very clear very simple
it does have tables with all the
different paper stocks
uh the different paper types and kind of
on the
on the glass table but as uh
viewers or visitors start touching it it
starts to kind of make different kind of
sounds
um so this is just very quick during the
exhibition
time people play with it and following
is a
short video that kind of like better
explain the experience of it
[Music]
yes
the idea is
[Music]
yeah so basically uh they are trying to
find out how
how we produce the sounds and everything
so it was quite a fun project
and and i think definitely it kind of
suits to
the team of emotive designs because
through our observations
we really see that people are react to
it
and they feel surprised they feel um
like
genuinely like react to to the discovery
i leave it to selfie next hi everyone my
name is selwyn
uh nice to meet all the fellow panelists
here and thanks henry for getting us
involved and
collaborating with jonathan on this
project um i have no
delicious food to show any of you but
i'm more of a special designer
and i was trying to understand maybe
sharing a bit more about emotive design
and whether from the space component can
we kind of look at social memory so
collective memories as a starting point
and also materiality so i'm just going
to share two very quick projects before
we talk about the actual exhibition
design
[Music]
the first project both projects are for
eso um the cosmetic brand
so the first project is actually in
kuala lumpur or selangor
and um for those of us in uh southeast
asia i think we're quite familiar
with malaysia and if you know selangor
used to be a teen
mining town and we wanted to take that
reference of how selangor used to be a
tin mining area
and the use of the corrugated tin
roofing
that you find across the landscape on a
lot of the old kampung houses
um it is very inherent in the vernacular
architecture
of malaysia and we took that as a
starting point
of how we could use a certain material
to form a student space or to craft a
space that relates to the history
or to the memories of the location so we
started looking into the opportunity of
stacking corrugated metals
look at the entire small design so this
is uh iso
in uh one utama kl
the space itself is entirely crafted
from a cast corrugated metal
the metal itself is also entirely
stacked up to form the support structure
for all the products
this is the entrance and what you're
looking at is the
window display as well as the seating
area
the entire space is very simple um we
use the
two ends of the wall to display the
products and they are entirely held up
by
a stack i believe we use almost like 12
000 metal sheets
for this uh space so it look uh very
simple
it was actually very difficult to hold
up the entire weight of the metal
structure
so something very wrong something very
honest something rooted in the material
language
and how that can be communicated into
the retail store design itself
we use the pattern as well to create
this series of uh
stack uh settings and the picture in the
middle actually shows how the
if you go to esop store you'll
understand a lot of the fragrance
actually
kind of kept concealed within the store
itself so that's where the
ascent will come out from and on the
right hand side the corrugated language
also extends to the facade where we
passed it in concrete
and then we have that full display
bottle what we thought was interesting
as well if you stay in the old
kind of attack house or in a corrugated
roofing is the sound of the rain water
dripping
in every soap store the basin is a very
kind of ritualistic
moment in this store itself if you
actually turn on the tap i think you
start to hear the slight drip sound
which is very different from a typical
basin
so this is in one with sama
in malaysia the second one is actually
in singapore orchard road
so again a very different location in
orchard itself
i think we were looking into the old
plantations for those of us who are
familiar
ochero itself used to be a plantations
for uh
gambia nutmeg and that was the starting
point
soil and perforated sheets that were
used in that plantation
the image here is actually how nutmeg
is being dried so nutmeg and mace
which is the red part in the middle is
actually placed on this series of
kind of timber racks in the past where
they were put it for about four months
and it was slowly dry it's also on a
kind of
porous metal sheets where it's used to
actually
kind of filter the different sizes of
nutmeg
we took our inspiration from this and we
wanted to find a way to actually kind of
create a quiet space in orchard for
those of us uh i think your family logic
is a really busy
retail area whether we can have a
calming space in a hard orchard
and having that kind of a story relating
to the past of the plantations and
orchard itself
so this is an ion this is the store
where we use a very simple series of
material which
is timber and perforated metal
which is the actual kind of drying racks
that's being used
however we inverted the relationship
between how the the metal used to be
supporting the wood
sorry the metal used we uh where the
nutmegs are but now they're supporting
the timber structure
in the in the center of the whole store
itself is this a basin
so we actually created this whole
perforated metal basin where the water
just disappear into it
as if like it's a very kind of magical
moment
the space entirely is rendered in a kind
of cast concrete
uh alluding to almost like the
plantation
soil in the plantations of the past
so there's another view of the store
itself
and this is the sink and how the
profession allows the water to actually
drain off magically
and this is just the ending image where
we wanted to have that
almost like bring back to a plantation
the raw tactility
of the space itself so i think
materiality
and history collecting memories are
important to us when we try to deal with
design
of emotive nature which brings me to the
next one which is about today's
show which we are at right now hungry
design
which is a collection of two dining
tables made entirely of cardboard
you want to join oh just okay
i think when we were tasked by henry to
look into a possible
design for the space itself packaging
but
also in terms of the amount of the
material wastage that it creates
uh we were thinking of whether there's
ability to kind of use some of this
material
salvaged um for the show itself
for those of uh the the foreign guests
who are not so familiar
national design center is also in
rochester rocha is an area where you see
a lot of uh
guaranteed or kabob collectors a lot of
times elderlies
will be seen on the street carrying a
lot of his cupboards so we wanted to
find a way to actually use the material
and potentially also giving back to the
to the community within this whole area
so i am showing some images which you
have seen
and for those who have uh well in
singapore i can
i hope that this will actually attract
you to come to the show itself
so this is a view of the two dining
table
made entirely of this corrugated uh
sorry may entirely of this
cardboard that was salvaged and they
were given actually by big retail brands
for example muji so they actually
donated all the cardboards for the show
itself
which would have otherwise been thrown
away we have made
two big dining tables uh in the middle
of
national design center and of which it
sits all the exhibits in the show itself
um yeah so you can see um you know
from this kind of like uh the idea of
two uh
dining table and then the skills of it
and
how we kind of like plans to have all
the packaging project
objects around it you know it's like a
delectable dishes
so from there kind of give us the idea
to um you know
uh you kind of recreate these kind of
like
dishes around the table as a typographic
forms for the identity of the exhibition
as well
so that kind of like the the exhibition
design the space itself echo with
kind of the branding itself usually as
well
so there's this cohesive language all
around so
um that's kind of like enter the whole
uh
branding trending look of it so from
there
um you know the whole series of the
applications and and all the collaterals
are
following the same language and
you know these are some of the thoughts
and ideas that we have for the
promotions
and i i guess one of the main things
when we when we kind of like
thinking about the visual graphics in
the space itself
as well is that we actually wanted to
kind of fly because all these objects
are uh uh like hundreds of all these
stunning projects all around
so we wanted to kind of like the space
details to have a
huge contrast as well so we actually
have this huge
uh you know the the whole branding kind
of flow from the table
to the floor to the wall as well yeah so
it created
kind of like a nice contrast of the
space the typography
versus the size of the objects all
around it so
we actually uh welcome you to come and
experience it it's hard to kind of show
this on the video as well
so for for this as well uh we kind of
talk about uh how to how do we have a
catalogue or you know a brochure so
can't take away
so we also talk about since it's a
packaging car for exhibition so we
wanted to take a way to have this
you know feeling like you're taking a
packaging home as well so we have this
uh it's a cube
that uh that kind of sell example from
a poster that's two-sided that you can
actually fall into the cube
so um yeah we have this
so we have a limited quantity so it's a
first-come first-served basis so
folded by chinatown yeah basically
folded by everybody
who's working on this exhibition so we
hope you kind of like uh
you know drop by when you're free and
really enjoys all the exhibited work
here which is uh
absolutely high high quality yeah yeah
i think that's so far that's right
that's all for us right thank you so
much thank you
thank you back to you charlotte
thank you next up we will move on to the
panel discussion and q and a portion of
today's segment
henry over to you okay
everybody how are you thank you for my
guest designers
give us such an inspiring presentation
today
my name is henry i'm the creator of this
hungry design show
founder of the top awards asia and i
live in tokyo for 25 years
since 2016 i followed my passion of
packaging design and started the
imitation only packaging design award
for asian market during these five years
top of what has been awarded over 500
great packaging design
around the world around asia and i can't
wait to share this great work for all of
you
so under the theme of march in motion
emotive
by design singapore console
we select more than 100 pieces of food
and beverage related products
and create a title called hungry design
to inspire people to think how
packaging design that somehow evokes our
emotion
and our daily life and also you can see
the exhibitions
right now is so so wonderful
so actually the show was scheduled last
year on march 2020
but under the kofi issue we will suggest
to postpone this
show for a year until today so i'm proud
so proud that singapore people can build
up a good record
to control kobe and under this issue
people's lifestyle change a lot as well
we are crossing over imperial so-called
new standard around us
at the same time establishing a
different point of view
to our shopping style as well so one of
the
obvious changes speeding up the
e-commerce development
development so because kovi we are free
if we are freely to go supermarket picks
and grab
products on the shelves enjoying our
five
senses shopping experience but nowadays
under the limit of people
con contact consumers are willing to
stay at home online shopping on their
tiny smartphone screen
instead of going out so under this
situation
packaging design works a very important
communication tool between
makers and consumer and also singapore
people are so lucky this time because
you can touch
and feel all the products in the
exhibition
but remember to put it back uh to the
same spot
thank you very much so moreover the
substance ability is also a rising topic
that are fighting for
for right now so uh in this
hungry design show thank you cyril
and jonathan created such a good
substantiality concept for the show and
make the balance between
designed and then filed
so i am proudly can invite six
iconic designers to share their opinion
today
so let us ask them uh some questions
uh make people to
to feel their hunger okay so
uh jo jo uh joshua
are you here
yes me okay so can i ask you the first
question
yes please okay uh you create
a very stylish design for the marble
chocolate
and matcha fuji tea green tea packaging
so what kind of mocking strike strategy
will lead this sophisticated food
product success
it's an interesting question i think um
in the case of the of the chocolate it
was um
there was a lot of delight and surprise
uh
inherent in this product it was a new
kind of product from from vietnam
and um honestly it was a lot of risk
taking
from the founders of the company and
their investors
but everyone really believed that um
the best option was to be
very honest about what this product was
all about and to bring this
into the market and allow people to
experience it and be curious about it um
one of the the risks that the founders
took
which was very much encouraged by us was
to
release six different products that come
from
it's it's basically all the same product
it's
dark chocolate but it comes from six
different provinces of southern vietnam
and because of the tewa and the way that
the farmers
work the land uh each of these
chocolates tasted differently
and i think this was like
in those days this was 10 years back we
wouldn't have really called that a
marketing strategy we would have called
that
following our instincts and just
believing in the fact that
people would want to take part in this
story and and
surely it was a big success um
you've also asked about material matcha
ujji i think that that was
quite calculated in that
matcha is obviously a revered
cherished very
um historic product
of japan and it was sort of the ambition
of these founders to
um almost disrupt that
and almost to challenge that and in a
way that in our
research of the the tea ceremony which
was originally
kind of a very um there were
there were tea ceremonies that were
quite elaborate and
very posh in this this revolution
to make it more simplistic and more
like we experience it today that was
destructive
to the culture of tea in japan at that
time and disruptive and that was
inspirational
sort of a bit of a punk revolution uh
on on matcha so we kind of got into that
and uh believed that that would be a
compelling way
to talk about matcha which is not so
much about
the tradition but more about just that
incredible ingredient which is the
inspiration for the tradition in the
first place
i hope that answers your question i i
didn't go much into a marketing strategy
but
this is a very great this is very great
answer i think
it's a very unique point of view to
create a very new
uh very old uh
things to the how to create a new market
i think your your your solution is very
inspiring
so for the next question i would like to
ask uh
esket kawasan
uh are you here yes i'm here okay
i find your food packaging with a lot of
delicious photos
so uh why are you focused such a lot of
photo and ingredients on your packaging
and why do you think this is the best
solution for your design
i say thank you for your question uh
i believe that the design and creativity
is a little bit similar to
the surviving of the environment
in evolution like features and
especially that uh
for focusing on quite competitive
uh market stations such as convenience
stores or
supermarket in that case that they are
many of the product is showing
themselves
uh so quite yeah sometimes that
it's very uh direct when when you use
the the photo itself uh for expressing
the sizzle
of the product uh so basically that
i believe when i use the photos
then this the cons the surroundings of
the product
is very tough in a way the environment
itself is
i see i see okay thank you thank you for
your answer
so uh the next question i i would like
to ask
uh eleko kawakami-san
instead of food photos you apply a lot
of illustration and artistic elements to
decorate the packaging
actually it is quite hard to uh for
designer to present such a very new
and we so call your hungry ideas
to your food related clients how
[Music]
foreign
maybe this is you have a lot of
products it's related to dessert and
like fakery things this is uh
more to be uh for our for stuck more
stylish fashion way to present
music
okay so for the next question uh
is uh
is are you here okay
hi can you hear me yes sure
okay good uh
you are very easy to tell that you are
very hungry
because the reason is i can see you have
a variety of projects yes
from interior packaging cafe and also
beside your packaging design you've done
a lot of restaurant and even you create
your
cafe shop next to your studio so yeah
i have two questions one is the way is
the design
inspiration come from and what is your
point of view
according to food and space relationship
then spacious relationship all right so
now i'm
i'm living in tokyo and also karizawa
you know
right yeah
that's that's right that's right so uh
kind of a swiss or some somewhere
yes so tokyo is very
modern and uh trans and
you know it's business fitting and it's
very quick
and karizawa is in the nature in the
forest
so i can feel more nature
so i could get so many inspiration from
city and nature you know and now in my
i'm living in half and a half
um four days in city three days in
karizawa three days in forest you know
so okay
so now i i could understand about
sustainability
why we need you know what i mean i see
yeah so so now um
i'm so much come so much inspiration
coming from forest and the nature
it's it's kind of everybody say sdgs or
something
you know assassinated so i'm trying now
i'm trying to
um design for design by sustainability
approach
and expert approach so using submitting
material and paper
uh don't want to food rules and you know
animal product and i'm thinking about
the background
of design all right so that's my
um inspiration coming from
you your brain is very very good point
is not only we
do research sustainability in front of
the computer
but you have to feel the real
nature yes this is very good okay and
you know
i'm born in tokyo and growing up in
shibuya
so so much talk about you know i am so
i'm so inspired from nature now
yeah so and also space and food
i'm thinking about everything
um as design what should i say
everything i want to organize
everything you know in design category
so
i'm trying to space design you know
architect ninja design also i'm i'd like
that
art direction and design direction uh
it's kind of collaboration
collaborating with architecture and
entry designer
for restaurant for shelf for
our space so and also we design
packaging and you know food packaging or
something
so i'm trying to combine the one
atmosphere for brand so space design
and also package design have to need
same
atmosphere so that's planning it's my
philosophy
okay thank you for your thank you very
much yes very
great answer it's very inspiring and
actually uh
can i ask us side save you
are you here service
yes actually you have uh you are uh very
similar to
uh uh kawakami-san kawakami because
both of you do of course you do mainly
is the space
project uh interior project and
actually i want to ask you is uh
uh it's very inspiring from your uh
soft project actually it's a worldwide
iconic skincare shop everybody knows so
is there any difference when you design
for
singapore market can we share some of
the
difficulties or some of the point of
view
for us um
[Music]
i think for east so uh thank you for the
question for eso itself uh what is
interesting is that every store is
unique
every store tells a local story every
store tries to be the local store
and which is why when we chat about the
projects
the starting point was always about the
location
and how to inspire by the history or the
culture of the location itself
so the singapore stores tells the
singapore store
which is very different from other
stores around the world so i think
there's a very strong starting point as
a brand
in how it lands certification itself so
i think that's a
very good starting point for us as
designers as well because then we can
uncover uh stories and emotional
aspects about that location and i think
that's a
there's something quite nice about the
brand
i see i see i see thank you very much
thank you very much
and uh jonathan are you here
yes okay so uh
my question is uh uh uh
because uh you know uh singapore is a
food paradise
for uh every is everyone knows
and with multicultural government
and uh for me under this kind of
multicultural
what is the difficulty when you design
an fmb design for singapore or
around the south east asia area
especially you talk about the odai otai
is a very traditional
food but you use a very contemporary
packaging
so can you tell us more about this one
this
question yeah um
for me um i always find that the
when it comes to kind of like um like
doing
brandings or even packaging designs or
any forms of designs for discount for
traditional foods and
and any kinds of you know foods in asia
is that how much we are able to you know
capture the original spirits
and how much we are able to kind of
elevate it so yeah it's always these
creative tensions that our feels
make or break the the the the creative
process
so for other itself um i i actually
trying to kind of
look at it from a modern point of view
like how much i
understand and then from this context
i will try to tell their story through a
more modern kind of eye of you
so hopefully with that i'm able to
communicate to a newer generation of
people consumers
and also kind of communicates to other
people who doesn't know what ota is
but able to kind of like understand and
first expose and
get fall in love with it in a more
contemporary kind of sensitivity uh
sensibility
so um yeah i think that will be
my my kind of a creative process and you
know
hopefully it's something that is kind of
reworkable
okay i see okay nice i say thank you
thank you very much
actually we got uh a few questions
from the uh audience and uh
uh this question is uh
joshua joshua are you here
yes i'm here okay uh actually
the audience want to ask is how much
time do you spend on research
before starting a conceptualization work
any advice on approaching this
i spend quite a lot of time on research
if we're working with a client um
outside
of vietnam we will go and
do our research in in person
most often we're working on projects now
in vietnam and
we will conduct often a workshop in the
beginning
getting all the stakeholders together
asking some
very careful questions that we've really
crafted and developed over the past 10
years
we use
questionnaires interviews trips
we want to get to know as much as we
possibly can
about the task and about how we can
help our clients solve a problem um
and of course when we're working there's
also just a lot of inspiration that
can come in in many different ways
uh we might spend up to a month on
research
in our in our projects it depends
um it depends on the task but
research and strategic work is
definitely the bulk
of the of the process and i think in our
experience
doing that diligently and doing that
very well
kind of leads us to
a more efficient design
discovery process where we might end up
just
presenting one solution to our clients
because
they've been with us the whole way
through we've been kind of solving
problems together and connecting the
dots
by the time we actually present design
it's almost
they kind of say it before we even say
it sometimes
so research very very very important and
it just solves so much
guessing okay thank you thank you for
your answer
and uh shun kawakami-san are you here
all right okay can i ask you a question
this uh
the audience want to ask is you are very
focused about sustainability so creating
an experience through packaging
and sustainability and reducing waste
can we truly find a balance between both
it's it's my thinking is very simple
um uh you know my design
my designs um don't want to be garbage
you know that's it almost that's it
because um i believe design
could make creating
sustainable business and culture
so i don't want to make garbage
sometimes pretty much packaging
i shall say to too much luxury packaging
sometimes we don't need
plants and enough
brands and business needs more thinking
about
for the future and for the
world better so
actually it's very simple um actually
clients
have to think about uh next era and the
future
for uh for hsa
uh
[Music]
m okay you you're very concerned about
the next generation
in the world yes yeah okay
so thank you thank you very much
can you ask you a question yes please
the question the audience want to ask
you uh can you talk
more about the your the most struggling
project
that means the most difficult the
project you are struggling
which one is your youtube project which
one is your
most struggling project and how did you
and your team solve the problem
uh okay uh so what you are asking is
the past project from our yes your
passport
just select one of it the most difficult
uh the the most difficult project
what i experienced is the the strategy
for the final disposal side of the new
korea garbage
okay and making the strategy of it
and what we proposed it is actually
there are
many of opposed people who are of course
uh actually that the you know that japan
is the second country actually uh
experienced the
uh the uh meltdown of the nuclear
plant uh so of course many people
opposing it but
but you know that there should be
in the final disposal site so uh what we
propose is for separating the strategy
uh from from the generating
the electricity from that
and the strategy for final disposal site
because the time frame is
so different and also that what we
propose is
with with writing it uh for
yeah as along the along the
federal teasers of sustainability we
set the concept of the that site
to to focusing on the
next generation of uh next generation
next generation of sustainable
sustainable plant and also the areas
uh with developing the world's largest
geiger counters
with with one kilometer one kilometer
size
width with the
mega solar so that is the kind of
that is the kind of hardest and also the
kind of invisible projects but
we really did but
uh though almost the every project is
the same
like yeah there are there's many of the
struggles and as soon
as said that for for thinking about
for yeah with with such struggling
uh hard situation actually
uh actually on the contrary uh we
uh we i mean that creatives
has a chance for flipping
freaking freaking situation upside down
if if the idea is right in a way
so so actually the
the hardest project can be the most
most exciting project i see
i see i under i i start to
envision how hungry how hungry
are you for your for the new things
okay i'm the time is running out so i'm
i'm
coming for the last question uh
uh salvi are you are you here
hi yes okay this is a question from the
audience it's very
very good question uh can you briefly
explain how do you explore your
materials
can you explain your train of thoughts
of how you can use such a common
material
for something so luxurious when do you
know
where to stop this is a very interesting
question
i i don't think there's a very clear-cut
answer to it is to keep an open mind
i think the start the starting research
that joshua talked about allows us to
probe
different types of the starting point it
also allows us
to understand how we can approach every
design brief
the materials might be different the
possibilities might be different
but the options are there and it's also
about constantly keeping an open mind to
what is possible
with very simple things and that's
something that uh i think we are quite
quite keen on i think materials have got
material properties as well
there is a limit to what you can do and
sometimes it's about
almost stress testing it but what are
the opportunity that it inherently has
so there will define a certain kind of
uh
possibilities in it knowing when to stop
is something that
i think is always a challenge because
i think as i mentioned earlier there is
a limit to what you can do
there is also a desire to push it
further
at the same time i think with all design
it's always about that balance between
when is right and often
we ask ourselves at least i do ask
myself this question whether the design
is right for the space
because we often operate in the realm of
the space itself
and uh yeah so i i don't think that's a
kind of hard and fast uh
way of knowing when to stop but you kind
of know when
is wrong or when it's right this is a
very good answer like uh
the hunger what are you hungry for so
actually everybody hunger cannot stop
you will not say tomorrow i'm not hungry
again
so every day you are hungry keep hungry
so actually it's very similar
our hunger is very similar to design so
actually it's kind of like a motivation
for us
to find more explore more to know more
so so thank you very much for six of you
taking
such a variable time today and sharing
such a good with a very very uh
inspiring content and also
especially especially thank you jonathan
and saiful help
us to establish such a beautiful
exhibition behind you i'm
because the kofi i cannot fly to
singapore to visit such a beautiful
event i hope you can take more photos
for us and i
really really recommend singapore people
with uh to to take a look of uh this
hundred more than hundred products and
ask yourself
what uh am i hungry for so i think it is
a very good question
like uh cyril said don't stop your
hunger
appetite no one stop advertising just go
forward and explore more
okay today thank you so much for
everybody
i think the time is over but uh it is
worth to take
to over the time because the content is
very interesting
so uh stay stay
strong and safe everybody okay
so thank you so much for your join and
uh
yes i hope look forward to have an
project with all of you in the future
thank you so much
thank you so much thank you thank you
everyone
your turn thank you henry all our
panelists
and every one of you who have joined us
today if you do not already know
the hungry design exhibit opens today
and will be ongoing till the 31st
of march as jonathan and selwyn
mentioned
this exhibition showcases more than 100
unique food packaging designs
from top awards asia's spectrum of
winners
visitors will get a glimpse into the
world of food and beverage packaging
through outstanding examples from around
asia
each of them has a delicatable
taste and a great story to tell
you can scan the qr code on the top
right corner
to find out more it is open daily from 9
00 am to 9 pm
at the national design center atrium
level 1.
we have come to the end of our session
and we would appreciate
if you could take some time to share
your feedback through a quick
survey by scanning the qr code on the
left
a link to the survey can also be found
in the zoom chat
please let us know what type of future
programs you'd be interested to see
from the national design center lastly
if you would like to find out more about
the upcoming programs
the national design center has lined up
under the much thematic of emotive
design
do scan the qr code you see on the right
thank you once again for spending time
with us and we hope to see you at our
future events
goodbye
you